soldiers welcome to the forge you'll be
making one of these
42 stiletto mcdagger specifically
designed for the Army Commandos of the
first special services Force for use
during Close Quarters combat during
World War II you have 10 series steel to
use to forge these blades good luck your
three hour starts now making this dagger
today is actually a very very difficult
thing to do because it's a quad Hollow
Grind quad Hollow Grind is where you
have actually Four surfaces that have to
be ground and they all have to match and
to get everything symmetrical and
everything straight is a very difficult
task
my game plan right off the top is
squashing that one by one piece of Steel
down the power hammer is taken when
stuff happened in the Army you gotta act
and not react
all right another option straight to the
Press
even though I can't get on the power
hammer in the meantime and making that
material move for me
so I'm trying to get everything as flat
as I can go ahead and get a point on it
make sure that it's nice and thin just
like the blade we're all having fun
we're brothers in arms there's nothing
like it once I have my point up too far
I take it to do a thermal cycle I think
two cycles should be enough
the reason why you do thermal Cycles is
because when you're given a Billet that
is so thick you're actually pounding
that metal together and in order for
that metal not to crack on you you have
to do this on thermal cycles that way
the metal can adjust to the temperature
my strengths in Blade smithing is I can
hit steel really hard so shaping comes
pretty easy
I did everything and it's stiletto do
you ever Hollow Grind before yeah
build branding is one of my things I
enjoyed I started my Holograms from the
ricasso all the way to the tip well firm
is throwing a lot of Sparks over there
I'm comfortable with the way the blade
is looking so now my next step is to get
that thumb rest on the blade now that's
a textured thumb Groove how do you do
that Jay quickest way to do it would be
to rotary tool just dimple it in there
doesn't get any better than that
I've got it profiled I've got it to
kind of my bevels now
on a piece like this I will spend a lot
of time on the grinder I need to make
these Holograms perfect and symmetrical
I hope those are lucky lips baby
before I get into the quench I'm looking
at my blade make sure that I'm not
overheating it make sure that it's got a
very nice golden color on it I can see
better now
all right so Furman has just quit
looks pretty straight to me
oh yeah it's hard yeah
what Jack's doing a smart heating up the
base of the blade or the ricasso is the
thickest point and we're using that
Rosebud torch can actually keep the heat
from traveling all the way to tipping
overheating
the tip on this stiletto is very very
fine it's almost needle-like and it's
very easy to pardon the end of your
knife off in the Forge
Jack finally went in the oil
what do we got what do we got coming out
of there
[Music]
we've got a problem over here gentlemen
this warp can send me home today so I
have to get this out
be careful
[Music]
it looks nice warp's gone
Tyler's in AOL yeah
I'm ecstatic with how it comes out of
the quench
it's nice and straight I don't see any
warps
so I'm going to proceed to the
thumbprint
put down your machines drop your tools
this first round of competition
late Smiths Welcome to our strength test
the weapon you made was required to have
a strong penetrating tip and a skull
cracker we're going to put both of those
to the test in this ammo can stat and
Bash not really concerned about what
your blades do the cans I want to see
what the cans do to your blades fireman
you're in first how you feel blood
pressure high that's all right get
medication for that yes I am on it all
right
if anything goes wrong with my blade it
might be the point because you're
stabbing metal and knowing Jay Nielsen
he's going to give it as all one
foreign
first off
the skull cracker there's nothing here
to stop my hand from moving so every
time I would strike
it would go all the way down to the can
so I could feel striking the can the
back of my hand your blade held up
though
we lost the very tip and because you had
that thin spot here
thicker steel here
and it wasn't fully corrected it's got a
flex in the blade but otherwise we
survived good job thank you sir
how you feeling Jack good good I know
you're looking forward to this oh yeah
yeah absolutely all right let's do it
then
seeing what furman's blade just went
through I hope my blade holds up but I
don't know about that damn pommel
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Jack first of all the point in the skull
cracker and the rib around it made a
nice penetrating of the three good
dimples in that can without any trouble
at all no movement on my hand sliding
back and forth your blade held up
beautifully Edge is great you got your
whole tip but your pummel's loosened up
and
apparently that pin came all the way out
we saw that you had a pin going in but
it didn't go all the way through so it
wasn't enough to lock everything
together
all right jack you've got a critical
failure in your weapon system your skull
crackers falling off now it would seem
that your fate lies in the hands and the
strength and integrity of Tyler's blade
Tyler you're up next if you pass this
test you'll be moving on and Jack you'll
be dismissed from the forge let's see
what happens
[Music]
all right Tyler are you ready you're
ready as I'll ever be well me too let's
go do it
foreign
to test and my heart's Racing 100 miles
an hour any little failure in my blade
it could be sending me home and lose a
chance to compete with that fifty
thousand dollars
oh
congratulations Tyler
your tip held up fine your edges are
still Sharp
it's all tight and good good job thank
you
Jack I feel terrible about this but the
fact is is that I have two complete v42s
over there and I have one that's missing
the skull cracker you can no longer be
measured evenly and fairly with your
competitors and for that reason I have
to ask you to please leave the forge
come on for it's our major thank you so
much thank you brother the blade was
perfect it performed phenomenally but
you got to have a handle on your knife
so
that's the end of it I may not be the
forge and fire Champion but I'm proud of
the work I did here I just want to tell
my fellow competitors out there to kick
ass and bring them home for the Army
thank you